good morning John VidCon date - what am
I gonna do in my video today well I got
to talk to a bunch of educational
YouTube creators recently so I decided
hey you know what everybody thinks these
folks are so smart what if I have some
bunch of trivia questions to see how
smarter they really are turns out pretty
smart because how many trivia questions
you know the answer to doesn't really
impact how smart you actually are but
regardless my voice here's the video of
a bunch of youtubers trying to answer
some trivia questions just make me
smarter United Service box Universal
something hub hub address service
burgers because all these are now
burgers United Service Bureau utility
saving button Universal Serial bus
talking about bears like very layer
there sunshine bear black bear no poo
bear
Oh polar bears roller Bears Ursa Major
Highland sloth bear a water bear that's
the correct answer
black there yeah absolutely it can
thrive whereas every other species of
bear has declined Oh No Lyndon Johnson
maybe does not making me smart wasn't
Johnson
I'm gonna go Gerald Ford and I just
don't know the answer seems to come out
of the ether to me drilled for Tibet I'm
gonna go to the ball huh India Tibet
don't know this I don't want to say
India that's why we watched geography
now it is in both Nepal and China that
exists there's one where I'm wearing a
beanie that I don't think it's held up
particularly well my first video isn't a
style of three six month yeah I make
physics videos now but I still have some
long hair tutorials on my channel decide
I made a video called spider versus
penis it's a good video I'm not ashamed
of that it's a good video when I made a
shake weight into a generator because in
my nose that seems to be the issue
[Music]
those little glow worms in the caves my
ex-boyfriend super creepy have you ever
encountered a zebra a night honey
pouches
oh uh like a scorpion scorpion so
scorpion scorpion scorpions and not
scorpion maybe a scorpion
Wow is it French don't know a lot of
French cooking good food lipet Amane was
a oh that was um the the move that
you do in order to soothe a dog
astronomy
sounds like a chemical sounds like it
could be a drug name that sounds like a
drug the active ingredient in imodium I
was so disappointed that nobody knew who
lahpet amine was come on and then after
the last person I quizzed was Kati
Morton and I was walking out and her
husband Sean who's amazing great friend
of Mines here it is also a witch do you
know who the pet amine is you'd be the
only person to get it right this is a
French man from France who could fart
and he was an entertainer so yay I can't
believe that we forget these amazing
things about history there was a guy who
was a professional farter anyway that's
all I got I got a do VidCon stuff now
John I'll see you like right after I go
out that door or before actually maybe
come on over
[Music]